wir sind heute in berlin es ist winter
und es hat eben geschneit
die mädchen frieren wie zittern vor der
kälte nicole kommt aus der ruhe
sie wohnt in lima dort ist das wetter
meistens besser als in berlin
in lima gibt es ganz viel sonne fast
jeden tag morgen gibt es manchmal auch
nebel und es gibt fast keine wolken am
himmel kommt aus kapstadt in südafrika
in kapstadt ist im sommer wär halt
manchmal 30 grad oder noch heißer
aber in kapstadt ist es sehr windig denn
die stadt liegt am kap im winter ist es
in kapstadt auch kalt aber nicht zu kalt
wie in berlin für jamie sind 15 grad
kalt der schnee ist ganz frisch
harry meist in wales gewicht
nicole und chemie versuchen einen
schneewall zu machen aber es gibt nicht
genug schnee um eine schneeballschlacht
zu machen
o eines neblung dankeschön in berlin
regnet es auch sehr oft dann wenn die
straßen nach so wie jetzt wir gehen über
die nasse straße janus geht rückwärts
über die nasse strafe jetzt wenn sie auf
dem bürgersteig das heißt wir fahren
keine autos
der himmel ist leicht bedeckt es gibt
einige wollen das wissen sieht man den
blauen himmel und den mond in berlin
scheint sehr oft die sonne
heute hat die sonne geschienen
jetzt geht die sonne unter
es wird dunkel
[Musik]